[Music]
happy birthday mr. adults man Omaha
flaca gross what was dad like as
beardless Scratchy
he had a goofy laugh I wish I bet him I
have something for you
sorry your dad it's a wizard staff
I wrote this spell so I can see for
myself who my boys grew up to be this
spell brings him back
back away back to life you wanted to
beat you more than anything
dad oh don't apart dad you are in your
house
[Music]
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean Cory she's
over there that's the manticore
[Music]
get in the vehicle an escort yo I'm
giving you to the count of three okay
wait what are you doing I don't know I'm
looking for my sons oh they went on a
quest
but don't worry I told him about the map
I told them about the gym I told them
about the curse your boys are in great
danger
hold
[Applause]
how do you boys do with a crisis
dead dead protect not great
I can't tell you we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this I believe in you
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
yes your group on my way boys just
[Music]
you